he was the one who started at all will
he be the one to end it while many fans
are speculating that a heavyweight hero
like Hulk or Captain Marvel won't be the
one to ultimately bring down the mad
Titan there are numerous reasons why
Thanos should fear Iron Man the most
stark first caught Thanos his attention
after thwarting his original invasion of
Earth back in the first Avengers film
even though Thanos himself wasn't
present at the invasion starts heroic
action still ultimately foiled the mad
Titans plans of conquering earth and
claiming the tesseract for himself a
being as driven and powerful as sorrows
would surely make a point to remember
anyone tenacious enough to defy his
whims this is exactly why Thanos knew
who Tony Stark was during Avengers
infinity war as confirmed by Joe Russo
during the commentary track for the
film's home release dork you know me I
do Bruce Lee went on to describe the
existential connection between the two
that stemmed from the first conflict the
fact that stark is the only Avenger that
Thanos knows and the dresses by name
already shows that the mad Titan views
him as a potential threat back in age of
Ultron Tony Stark actually predicted the
events of infinity war with frightening
accuracy during a heated exchange with
Steve Rogers Tony's concerns about an
unstoppable threat from space not only
referenced the Battle of New York but
also foreshadowed the arrival of the mad
Titan with Avengers we can bust arms do
it on the live long day but that up
there that's that's the again
not only did stock predict the title
event game during this verbal tirade he
also foretold their defeat at the hands
of Thanos will lose and we'll do that
together too
The Avengers eventually give it all they
have but they weren't enough to stop the
mad fighting from collecting the
Infinity stones Rogers might be the
courageous leader who the heroes look up
to in the darkest of times but Stark is
the only real lists on the team trying
to plan ahead before disaster strikes
tony is an canny ability to
realistically anticipate what the future
holds as another reason fellows should
be wary of him long ago Thanos foresaw
the downfall of his own civilization due
to overpopulation and exhaustion of
resources despite his best efforts the
people of fightin wouldn't listen to his
call for action understandably
due to his radical idea of eliminating
half the population although Starks
ideas were drastically different from
Thanos says it was the same fear for his
people that drove him to misguide Li
create Ultron Tony created the murder
bot to combat future threats but in
doing so he was giving in to the very
same kind of fear that drove the knows
to concoct his genocide of balance this
is yet another reason that Thanos fears
stark he respects Tony's efforts to
protect his planet and knows that the
iron Avenger will stop at nothing to
defend earth hardest choices require the
strongest wounds throughout the grand
arc of the MCU Stark has steadily
improved his suits to adapt to various
threats and situations
Tony's knack for modifying his tech was
highlighted in the first Iron Man film
when he faced off against uber daya
stains Iron Monger ama after realizing
that his titanium steel mouth to armor
would freeze up the high altitudes Sark
reconfigures it using a gold titanium
alloy that could enjoy lower
temperatures this small tweak helps Tony
defeat shame by luring him up high into
the atmosphere where his nemesis his
suit freezes over
how'd you saw the icy problem whose
problem
my one look into it Sark uses this
innate adaptability to turn his
perceived failures into learning
experiences drawing civil war James
Rhodes suffers critical injuries after
being shot down in his war machine armor
so Tony develops a parachute for the
iron spider armor he gives to Peter
Parker in infinity war after a man
shrinks down and damages his suit
drawing Civil War
Tony switches to nanotechnology after
being defeated in hand-to-hand combat by
Steve Rogers and Bucky Barnes he learns
to use his nanotech to create melee
weapons around his hands such as
battering rams blades and shields each
defeats and failure that Stark and yours
only makes him stronger one fan theory
claims her as evidence
Tony uses the Infinity stones in the
future the evidence the fact that his
left arm has bothered him in previous
films as we see at the end of infinity
war even fallows himself is wounded by
the exertion of carrying out the
decimation if Tony attempted to reverse
the snap using the Infinity stones
chances are it would seriously injure if
not completely obliterate erm the force
of use in the Infinity stones could be
so powerful that the pain reverberates
through time and Tony feels some type of
a - ripple effect my left arm is normal
Iron Man wielding the Infinity Gauntlet
would come full circle with the comics
in which he has used it before to defeat
a bad guy who calls himself the hood
from the end game trailers we know Tony
is drifting through space in the Benatar
with nebula as the adopted daughter of
Thanos she has incredibly intimate
knowledge about the abusive multi-turn
even though she might not be aware of it
nebula could hold the secret to
defeating Thanos a secret that only
someone has brilliant to star could
deduce pairing together nebula with Iron
Man is no coincidence especially since
the Russo brothers confirms that she
plays an important role in the plot they
told The Telegraph when you're dealing
with characters like nebula a child of
Thanos it's impossible not to make her
integral to the story or have an
emotional connection to her although
Thanos probably does not have any type
of obvious weakness star could utilize
nebulas knowledge of her adopted father
to get inside his head and predict his
next move when the first time on movie
back in 2008 - led the charge of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe Tony Stark's
actions essentially kicked off the
series of events that led to infinity
war he
though Tony could have never predicted
how far his superhero adventures would
take him it would certainly be poetic
for the one who started it all to end my
turn
Tony Stark was a completely different
person when he first hit the scene and
his character arc is one of redemption
from its history as a weapons developer
to his guilt over the lives lost due to
the Avengers actions in sokovia Sarkis
felt an increasing amount of
responsibility for the suffering around
him although he has made efforts to
atone face sins
he remains a tortured soul this need for
atonement that has driven stark over the
past few films could very well be
building toward the ultimate sacrifice
that he almost made in the first
Avengers movie since Robert Downey jr.
contract expires after endgame many fans
are speculating that Iron Man will
sacrifice himself to save the others
when Thanos easily dismantles the entire
cast of Marvel heroes during infinity
war he seems content to simply
incapacitate his enemies instead of
murdering them outside of the snap the
only characters he ends up killing
personally are Heimdall Loki Gamora and
vision each of whom he offs for a
specific reason as the Russo brothers
pointed out on the Infinity walk
commentary track Tony is the only
Avenger that Thanos goes out of his way
to try and cure from the start this is
interesting because I am man is not a
strongest Hulk or Thor yet Thanos leaves
them alive after defeating them tano
specifically sets out to kill Stark but
as he perceives him as a real threat and
when he says hope to remember you he
seems to think he succeeded when it
comes down to it the main reason that
his respects and fears Tony is simply
how in light they are the Russo brothers
touched upon this join their interview
with The Telegraph Joe Russo said Tony
is the most desperately driven down to
the core to react against something like
the nose I think this is intrinsic to
Tony's psychology and because Tony
started it all with Iron Man he has a
special connection to the threat that's
facing him this is how the nose knows
Tony will do whatever it takes to stop
him the mad fightin sees too much of
himself and Stark and that frightens him
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Avengers and game are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]